it's happening today because we're
seeing the worst changes to education
and decades what's happening right now
with the cats to maintenance grounds the
changes to loan conditions prevent visas
of international students being canceled
all of these changes possible higher
tuition fees is much worse than the
tripling of tuition fees in 2010 and a
scrapping of EMA we demand a free
education accessible democratic for all
students free of barriers free of bear
borders and three-year business and
that's why students are here and excited
to match day through London but I guess
a lot of people would say fantastic if
there could be free tuition but the
government might argue there's not
enough money and universities do need to
have sufficient funds to provide high
quality education and they say this is
the best possible system they say that
tuition fees are progressive it's the
people that benefit from from education
from university who are the ones who are
paying not all of taxpayers who might
choose not to go to university so first
of all tuition fees are actually only
like a small percentage of the many
universities receive and not the whole
and up the whole story and actually
since like the government has recently
put out reports which make it clear that
the fee system now is actually worse for
the tax further taxpayer than the system
we head into the on 10 because loans am
being repaid and because of the way it
works and so what we arguing for is that
we need a more progressive taxation
system and Jeremy Corbyn you know may
destitution people edge in this campaign
he said all we would need to do is
increase corporation text by 2.5% and
we'd be able to pay for the 10 billion
that we need to have free tuition and
maintenance grants for all students I
think there would be much fairer than
the poorest students having 53,000
pounds of their life well yes and no one
likes the idea of debt however it would
appear that since this tuition fee
system has been in place poor students
don't appear to have been put off
according at least two at the university
and colleges of mission service figures
in 2014 more people apply than ever
before to university and the number of
places rose by at
ten percent amongst those who are poor
will let well off yes I think that
number is quite flawed actually because
what we've also seen since around 10 is
places and universities being increased
because obviously universities receive
so much of the funding now from students
directly universities have given out
much more players it's actually more
than they have space for we've seen
students you know sitting on staircases
in lecture halls but we've also seen is
part time students dropping by
forty-eight percent since nine ten and
part-time students that for sure
students that's parents that's working
class students for not going to
university anymore but I think what's
worse in 2010 when they've come and use
the Tutan clear eyes he said we are
going to make sure that every student
can still go to university and that's
why we're going to increase the money
for grants and that's exactly what
they're taking away now they're cutting
maintenance grants which 1 million of
the poorest students rely on in order to
go to university and one-third of them
can you get this ground to said they
would have not been able to go to
university if it wasn't for these brands
ok we'll Deborah Herman's a student
organizer for the national campaign
against a fees and cuts thanks very much
indeed for your time